if you go down to the woods today you're
sure for a big surprise if you go down
to the woods today you'd better go in
disguise for every bear that ever there
was will gather there for certain
because today is the day that teddy
bears have their picnic except there are
no teddy bears in this forest and the
early picnic is you and your children
deep inside the center of this forest
you'll find a clearing a small patch of
land separate from the rest marked by a
picket fence made of human bones there
you will find the hags hut where there
is a phrase you need in order to enter
turn your back to the forest
your front to me if your children are
indeed alive then I wish you the best of
luck for this is her forest if you are
too late then it doesn't matter because
very few ever return and those who do
never go back and they never speak of
what they saw at least most of them some
foolishly believe that they can help
others before she comes back to finish
what she started whereas the rest
believe what they saw wasn't real the
boogeyman is just a story told to scare
children and she is no different
baba Yaga is just the name or is it
most of us remember those stories we
were told as children that attempted to
scare us into behaving ourselves whether
it was the boogeyman a Christmas demon
or a cannibalistic witch in the woods
they all had the same intention today we
are indeed diving back into the
wonderfully weird world of Slavic
folklore with the tale of Baba Yaga or
Baba Yaga for anyone planning on leaving
a John wick reference now is your time
to leave your pencil related comments
down below if you've been following a
channel for some time then you may know
that Baba Yaga was actually the third
video that I ever made but looking back
at it now that video is terrible and it
doesn't really do the story any justice
so here we are with what I can only hope
is a far more compelling script and some
awesome original artwork created
specifically for this video which is
only made possible by you guys and girls
who keep coming back
but with that introduction and
explanation out of the way let's get
back to today's video
baba Yaga is a name that appears all
across the Slovak territories of Europe
but the origin and meaning of this name
much like Slavic folklore in general is
a bit all over the place now as someone
who doesn't speak any of these Slavic
languages babushka is the first word
that comes to mind but that may also
just be because it's the only word I
remember that isn't a curse word the
word Bubba itself seems to be rooted in
several Slavic languages and today it's
commonly used to refer to an elderly
woman or one's grandmother just like
babushka in all the forms of Russian it
was used to refer to a midwife and even
a fortune-teller so it's hard to take
any real definitive meaning other than
woman the second part of the name Yaga
or Yaga is even more ambiguous than the
first meaning anything from anger and
horror to which evil and serpent this
led many to believe that barber could
have simply helped to distinguish or
identify a female character so I guess
an evil or scary elderly woman is as bad
as close as we can get to a direct
translation with Baba Yaga we have a
very interesting and unique
character because her story is not the
classic one-dimensional boogeyman or a
guess boogey woman s story that you may
have come to expect it's almost like
telling your children that if they
misbehave Baba Yaga the evil old hag
will come and eat them but if they're
good she's a sweet old grandmother
figure who will help them the characters
in these stories may almost be the polar
opposites to each other but it shows
that there is more to Baba Yaga than
just an evil sight despite how different
these two approaches are the goal of
these stories is ultimately the same to
make children behave whether that's
through the fear of consequence or an
alluring incentive listen here little
Timmy you Betty those Brussels sprouts
or that creepy old woman across the
street is gonna eat your heart and grind
your bones into dust to snort later you
want that to happen
no eat your vegetables but if you're a
good little Timmy who eats all of his
Brussels sprouts then baba Yaga will
help you when you're in need to pretty
different approaches but the goal is the
same to stop little Timmy being a turd
now I know some of you may not like the
idea of death threats bribery and
scaring kids into behaving themselves
and you're probably right it's not
exactly the most healthy practice I'm
sure nowadays taking your child's phone
away and telling them no more fortnight
Timmy is the equivalent to the
modern-day boogeyman but that's nowhere
near as fun or interesting so who was
Baba Yaga and what was her story the
first recorded mention of her name was
by the Russian author Mikhail Lomonosov
in his work Rossi skirt gramatica which
pretty much just means Russian grammar
here McHale mentions her names twice
with one of these being in a section
where the Slavic deities are compared to
the Roman deities their inspiration was
presumed to have come from but Baba Yaga
appears by herself reinforcing the
notion that she was a unique Slavic
creation void of any Greek and Roman
influence as the years went by stories
of an old bony hag who lived in the
woods began to spread her house stood on
two chicken legs and she rode around
through the forest in a Jay
in pestle and mortar and this is why I
enjoy Slavic folklore because it's so
unapologetically weird that is hard to
not be amused by it when you think of
which is the most generic image that
comes to mind probably involves a
pointed hat a black cat and a broomstick
to ride around on but not the Slavs
instead baba-yaga climbs inside of her
giant mortar and uses her equally as big
pestle to steer which when you really
think about it is actually quite
efficient because when you're kidnapping
children and grinding their bones to
dust you're gonna want to have your
pestle and mortar at hand when you
finally catch one of the little gremlins
she does still carry around a broom but
this is the sweep away any trash you may
have left so disgruntled villagers can't
find her in the different stories and
narrative she appears in Baba Yaga does
have several depictions with some quite
interesting symbolism behind them she
may have a frail shape but her teeth are
sharp enough to nor threw bones and
sometimes even depicted as being metal
her legs are often extremely skinny
which lends to one of her nicknames
boney leg this is often thought to imply
some kind of demonic influence or power
because of a poem by Nikolay necklace of
in 1840 the poem was titled Baba Yaga
the bony leg in this poem he says the
devil cooks 12 evil women into one to be
just as evil as himself and the result
is Baba Yaga who goes out into the world
to do evil and returns to hell for her
reward
necro sauce description is as follows
she has fangs and nostril hairs so long
they hang down to her breasts she has
huge ears horns on her forehead and
holes instead of eyes were in a toad
skin cap and a snakeskin coat clearly
nekrasova Sora is more of a demon than a
sweet old lady an interesting piece of
symbolism comes from her house or hut
which stands on two chicken feet and is
able just to get up and walk away at any
time strangers also can't just walk into
their house without saying the phrase
turn your back to the forest at your
front to me
whether this cause the door to appear or
simply unlocks the front door is down to
your own imagination but the first
certainly has a more magical feel this
phrase was also thought to stop the
house when it's moving through the
forest when it comes to Baba Yaga's
house the obvious question is why does
it have chicken feet I remember when I
first heard the story I just brushed it
off as well everyone loves chicken
obviously but when you look at it from a
more symbolic point of view it makes a
tad more sense Bubba a guy's often shown
as either a grandmother or croon figure
and then there's her more sinister side
which is ugly dangerous and wild
regardless of which you'd expect both
those figures to be somewhat resourceful
a grandmother using whatever she can
find to feed her family and the same can
be said for someone isolated living in
the woods there's no choice but to be
self-sufficient so how the hell does all
of this tie into chicken feet
well the feet would have been seen as an
undesirable part of the chicken and I'm
sure there are people out there who are
just like what is this guy talking about
chicken feet are delicious and I'm sure
they are but when it came to royalty
heroes and the wealthy they would have
had their choice cut the wings the
breasts or the thigh but the less
desirable parts of the chicken such as
the feet would have been either thrown
out or given to the peasants and no that
isn't me calling you a peasant if you
eat chicken feet you're just the weirdo
who eats chicken fee so Bobby a guy then
building her house out of unwanted
scraps is a testament to her
resourcefulness and maybe it's meant to
show regardless of how something may
appear everything has its use there are
some however who believe these chicken
feet were actually just stilts and this
belief stems from the indigenous people
of Siberia who would store their food in
small huts supported on stilts to keep
their supplies away from animals the
roots of these trees may at times
resemble chicken feet there's also some
symbolism behind her pestle and mortar
which at first glance may just seem like
a weird choice to travel around in for
those who don't know a pestle and mortar
is often used to grind all sorts of
things but mostly herbes and spices so
it would have been used by physicians
and
others attempting to make medicine but
it also would have been used by those
practicing witchcraft
so the pestle and mortar can be seen as
symbolizing her two personas one of the
most famous stories she appears in is
the fairy tale vassilisa the beautiful
witch was part of a collection of tales
collected by Alexander Afanasieff
as you may have guessed the story
centers around a young girl named a
vassilisa when she was eight years old
her mother passed away and left her a
small wooden doll she told vassilisa
that issuer's ever in need of help all
she had to do was feed the doll and it
would aid her when her mother died she
gave the Dolson food and it came to her
and comforted her eventually her father
moved on and married once again but this
stepmother was a wicked and cruel woman
who worked vassilisa to the bone but
with a wooden doll by her side she was
able to perform each task that was asked
of her as the name of the story tells us
vassilisa was extremely beautiful and
she was often visited by young men who
expressed their interest
her stepmother rejected all proposals
from these suitors because her daughters
were older and thus they should be
married first but none of the suitors
would choose them over vassilisa and so
she was stuck at home slaving away her
father being a merchant had to embark on
a rather long journey and her stepmother
took advantage of this selling their
home and moving them into a dark and
gloomy forest on one particular evening
each girl was told to put out all of the
fires in the house except for one candle
however one of the older daughters put
out this candle by mistake and the
vassilisa was held responsible
her stepmother then sent her to retrieve
the lights they had lost from Baba
Yaga's Hut the young girl was unsure as
to whether this was a wise idea because
she had heard tales of Baba Yaga before
and these only filled her with dread so
she took out her wooden doll and fed it
some crumbs it calmed her nerves and
then advised her to go see Baba Yaga
early the next morning she began her
journey as she ventured further into the
forest she came across a man dressed in
all white ride in a white horse who paid
her no attention not long after
another man rode by this time dressed in
red with a red horse she then came
across a fence made of human bones that
surrounded a house that stood on two
chicken legs as she stood there
contemplating whether or not she should
go inside a third rider came by this
time dressed in black and with him came
nightfall the skulls that made up the
fence began to glow but vassilisa
determined to retrieve the light
remained by the fence until Baba Yaga
came flying by in her pestle and mortar
only to find a young girl waiting for
her she agreed to give Vasily's to the
fire that she came for but only if she
completed a series of tasks first this
also came with the caveat that if she
failed then she would kill the child but
to her credit she accepted this offer
these tasks however were no different to
what she was doing fire stepmother and
consisted of cleaning cooking and doing
laundry but when those chores were done
she would have to separate poppy seeds
from the soil and the good corn from the
rotten corn the sheer amount of work
that needed to be done was too much for
vassilisa who was exhausted she began to
lose all hope until her doll came to her
aid once again completing the work while
she slept at the crack of dawn the white
horsemen rode by followed by the red in
the afternoon and the black horsemen in
the evening with this last horseman Baba
Yaga returned home she inspected the
work done by vassilisa and had no
complaints with her she had three pairs
of severed hands that inspected the corn
for her she then explained that the
white Rider was day the red was the Sun
and the black Rider was the night
knowing that a task she set the girl
were almost impossible she inquired as
to how she was successful
vassilisa replied with her mother's
blessing this enraged Baba Yaga and she
told the girl that she would have no one
of a blessing of any kind in her house
she gave her a skull ant and full of
burning coal from her fence and sent her
on her way home when vassilisa returned
home she found out that her stepmother
and stepsisters were unable to light any
of the candles or fires in their home
they tried bringing lamps and
Porter's from outside but the second
they stepped inside they were snuffed
out the calls that she bought with her
in the skull however burn bright so
bright that they engulfed her stepmother
and stepsisters burning them to ashes
she then buried the skull underneath her
house so it could cause no more harm
vassilisa then moved to the capital and
became a cloth maker where her
exceptional skills meant she would work
for the royal family and eventually
marry a prince this sari is interesting
because it fits the description of
bhabhi ago we mentioned earlier she
isn't entirely evil as she's willing to
help vassilisa but she has to earn it
and then we see the slightly darker side
when she tells the girl that if she
cannot perform these tasks then she'll
kill her the reason she had such an
aggressive reaction to vassilisa
mentioning her mother's blessing may
have something to do with the stories of
Baba Yaga being the devil's grandmother
so naturally she would have an aversion
to the idea of blessings and all sorts
of things that would ward off evil we
also see the introduction of the
horseman in this story I know when I
mentioned the three horsemen in the
previous video a lot of people seem to
think I had them confused with the Four
Horsemen of the Apocalypse but they
don't seem to have much relation the
three horsemen are instead symbolic of
the day the Sun and the night it's
common for Baba Yaga to be described as
having control over the elements within
the forest and the horsemen are a pretty
good example of that what also stood out
to me were the parallels between this
story and other popular fairy tales such
as Cinderella
you have the underappreciated main
character the wicked stepmother making
her do chores and the ugly stepsisters
another story that instead highlights
the idea of Baba Yaga as this triple
Crone figure that we see in games such
as The Witcher 3 is the maiden of SAR
which follows a merchant son named Ivan
as he visits the home of all three
bubble guards when he arrives at the
first house he is greeted by a very old
woman he asks her if she knows where the
thrice tenth Kingdom is to which she
responds that she does not but her
sister may Ivan continues to the forest
until he comes across a hut
identical to the first but inside is a
much younger looking woman and he asks
her the same question she also tells
Ivan that she doesn't know and maybe her
other sister may know but she also warns
Ivan that this system may try to eat him
if this should happen she tells Ivan to
ask her sister for three horns and her
permission to blow them the first must
be blown softly the second louder and
the third even louder after some time
Ivan comes across the same hut once
again and inside is the youngest of all
three sisters as the other sister
predicted she plans to kill Ivan and eat
him he pleads with her to give him the
three horns and seen though harm in
doing so she does he blows on the first
softly then louder with the second and
as loud as he possibly could with the
third blowing these horns caused the
house to be swarmed by hundreds of birds
among these birds is a giant Firebird
which tells Ivan to jump on its back so
they can escape before he's eaten and
they do so and that is the end of the
story in the witcher 3 you have a quest
line that centers around the ladies of
the wood or the three crowns which
appears to be a reference to the stories
of Baba Yaga as three sisters when we
first see them in a tapestry they appear
as young and beautiful but later in
person they are all decrepit and quite
repulsive on their person we see severed
hands and toy dolls referring back to
the story of vassilisa but we also see
other body parts of children as well as
talk of eating young boys and girls
there's even a rider dressed in a black
suit of armor that does their bidding
none of this is really a surprise
because CD Projekt RED are very good
when it comes to integrating traditional
folklore into the witcher and the scenes
with these three Crone's are a testament
to this i think the most recent
depiction we see of Baba Yaga in the
mainstream is the Hellboy movie where to
say she isn't the most pleasant looking
individual is the understatement of the
year without spoiling too much she's a
one-eyed hag
wooden legs and a taste for human
children
Bubbe our guys a figure shrouded in
mystery we don't really know how old she
is or where she came from it's this
ambiguity that makes her a great
character and she has featured in
numerous animations and movies where she
appears as both the villain and as a
more helpful individual though some
question if she was ever meant to be
seen this way implying she only helps
when it's in her own interest there are
even some questions over her status as a
witch because although she has been
labeled as such and may even behave and
possess some of the qualities you'd
expect there are many factors that do
not fit the stereotypical image we also
have no definitive answer as to where
these stories originated from many of
the written mentions and stories came
from Russian scholars but there are
references to a figure named JZ Baba
from the Western Slavs and Baba charisma
or Baba Yaga from the southern Slavic
region so it's pretty safe to say that
she appeared everywhere amongst the
Slavic people in various different forms
and by a host of different names so
which interpretation do you prefer an
evil witch who devours children a kind
old lady who helps those in need or a
self-serving elderly woman who is
neither good nor bad but merely driven
by self-interest maybe you prefer the
three sisters that appear in The Witcher
and the story of Ivan let me know in the
comments below and if you are someone
who grew up with these stories I'd love
to hear from you as always I've been
your host mythology and fiction
explained reminding you to eat your
Brussels sprouts especially if your name
is Timmy
you